so i don't know about you guys but every
time i think i've explored 100 of this
game i am consistently surprised by the
amount of content that i just seem to
miss i've beaten this game four times
now all with at least 50 hours of play
time between them and i just now found
the entrance to reichard's divine tower
where you can receive his great room now
most of you guys are smarter and better
than i am at these games but i've really
tried to avoid looking up how to do
things in elden ring and for the longest
time i just couldn't find the entrance
to this divine tower i even went inside
this cave multiple times and just
thought it was a very basic cave that
had nothing in it my original thought
was that i had to find a teleporter that
would take me to the tower just like i
had to do for the isolated tower but
during my fifth playthrough i decided to
give it another try basically it really
did seem like the only possible route to
the divine tower it's the closest cave
system to the tower itself the cave is
also named the sealed tunnel which
indicated that something is obviously
being sealed away and after exploring
more of the cave there are multiple
invisible walls which has been a major
rarity in elden ring compared to dark
souls there are actually three or four
invisible walls in this tunnel alone and
it leads to some very interesting areas
that i'd like to lure hunt through with
you guys today making my way through the
sealed tunnel brought up a lot of
questions for me like what are they
mining in this area are they looking for
the same invisible walls that i had to
find are they the ones that sealed it
away in the first place these mining
enemy npcs do seem to be infatuated with
the meteoric elements that are spread
around in the lands between like they'll
constantly be mining in caves where
there are crystals or other meteoric
elements and exploring further into this
cave we find an onyx lord and upon
defeating this boss we receive his
greatsword that reads a weapon unique to
the onyx lords a race of ancients with
the skin of stone who was said to have
risen to life when a meteor struck long
ago that's likely what this meteor on
the map is i've always been so curious
of why this is here we also know that
these onyx lords are at least one of
them who went on to be the sorcerer
master and radon's teacher but that
doesn't mean there's only one onyx lord
there's probably multiple of them so
either the entrance to reichard's divine
tower was sealed away by the capital
city and the golden order or the onyx
lord sealed himself and the tower away i
say that maybe the capital city and the
golden order sealed away this divine
tower because the story of reichard is
embarrassing to the lineage of the
golden order itself as reichardt is one
of the demigod children of ratagon and
rinala again reichard would be
considered a demigod's stepchild since
ratagon would go on to be queen
america's consort reichardt is an
embarrassment since he decided to feed
himself to the great serpent for reasons
that i have not found yet his great rune
reads reichard was amongst the children
of ranala and radagon who became demigod
stepchildren of ratagon's union with
queen america reichardt fed himself to
the blasphemous serpent great rune and
all so clearly reichardt didn't care
much for the responsibilities that came
with obtaining the power of a great room
or maybe he just didn't want to be a
part of the war between all his brothers
sisters and step siblings i'm curious of
what you guys all think may have been
the reason reichardt decided to be
consumed by the great rune serpent maybe
it was just to obtain more power which
is my best guess he doesn't really seem
to be liked by anybody in his family but
as i said i feel the family lineage was
stained by reichardt's decision and they
sealed this divine tower away so none
could bear witness or even remember his
existence it also probably has a lot to
do with the volcano manor whose entire
point is to be rid of the golden order
itself maybe he did it all just despite
his family who knows it's funny to me
that all these demigods and the family
would just disregard morgot and banish
him to the sewers below of the capital
city just because he was born as an omen
morgot was clearly the most loyal to the
family its lineage and its reputation
definitely more so than reichardt and
godric who if you guys didn't know this
godric does not seem to be a child of
america and ratagon or at least that's
what i can read from his great rune i
didn't know that till today which is
very interesting so it seems like godric
just stole godwin's great rune and then
just went crazy with the grafting
process nobody in the family line seems
to like godric whatsoever but it's
interesting to see that he's not
actually a descendant he was just
powerful enough being godwin's offspring
that he could obtain the power of a
great rune and then it seems like he
just disregards his father's body down
to the bottom of stornville castle this
is such an interesting thing to look
into that we will look into more and who
knows maybe it was morgot who sealed
away the entrance to reichard's divine
tower he's clearly not happy with all
his siblings and their fickleness to the
golden order itself we've all heard how
he feels
ah
godric the golden
the twin prodigies
michela and melania
general pradhan
prata reichardt
luna princess ronnie
willful traitors
this guy was banished as an omen and
still remains so devout to the cause of
his family's line his story really is a
sad one and so is all of elden rings in
my opinion it's very clear that this
tower was sealed away or at least the
tunnel was sealed away so that nobody
could find it and when we scale
reichard's divine tower we get the best
view of the other divine towers in the
lands between we can see all of them and
if you didn't notice this before these
divine towers are placed in a circle
meant to represent a ring putting all
the great runes together would make the
elden ring so it's cool they're placed
in a ring themselves i always wondered
if it was in a literal sense that queen
america shattered the elden ring maybe
she destroyed one of the divine towers
that we just simply don't know about to
technically destroy the elden ring
because we've been to all the divine
towers except for mykolas we have yet to
find his great room we can receive a
great rune from godric melania radon
morgot reichard and moogue but still no
sign of nicolas very interesting we'll
likely have to wait for future dlc to
learn more about mykola which i'm very
excited about i've seen some theories on
twitter that we'll be able to access
future dlc by touching nikola's hand and
he'll teleport us through time or
something like that it's almost like the
world of elden ring is set up to have
future content added to it for years to
come it's all very exciting i can't wait
thank you guys for watching the video
and continuing to support this channel
make sure to like subscribe and join our
discord community so we can discuss more
things of the world of elden ring take
care and i'll see you all in the next
video
[Music]
you